eux sont pas trop atteints le feu
les plus atteints ça peut arriver que
les pétales vont noircir mais que le
coeur est encore vivant le gel de la
nuit dernière aura des conséquences sur
la production de pommes d'Alexandre
sauvé il a travaillé toute la nuit à
allumer des feux pour sauver son verger
on se promenait aussi avec des tracteurs
dévastateurs pour brasser cette chaleur
là pour empêcher que le gel tombe sur
les plans
la to - 2 de
gré c'est dans la nuit de mercredi
de base
si m'avoir perdu 10% de sa production
elle a le
[Musique]
c'est vraiment les températures chaudes
qu'on a en avril qui change beaucoup la
donne contrairement avant que la chaleur
arrivait au mois de mai donc tout
décoller tranquillement du côté des
producteurs maraîchers le maïs et les
asperges sont particulièrement touchés
un gel aussi important et aussi tardif
là on n'a pas vu ça depuis la fin des
années 70 début des années 80 difficile
encore d'évaluer l'ensemble des pertes
certains endroits dans l'anaudière qui
sont plus touchés que d'autres même
chose pour la montée rigide plus qu'on
se rapproche de l'Estrie plus que les
dommages sont importants
courte nuit aussi pour les producteurs
de vin on est à notre cinquième nuit
qu'on dort avait à surveiller nos
alertes là on est sur une zone grise ou
est-ce que certains bourgeons dans
certaines zones vont avoir été affectées
mais peut-être ont quand même capable de
pousser
le combat des agriculteurs
n'ira toujours froides sont encore
à piscine à Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada
Salaberry de Valleyfield